I'm very happy um that you're listening
today and I want to introduce myself I
want to tell you the story about Mike
myself
um 10 years ago
and
um back then I was in Spanish class and
the next day I had to hold a
presentation about Columbus and to be
honest this was not my favorite subject
and there was not a problem
um
I had not much time to prepare prepare
the presentation because of course I had
to play
um soccer with my friends the whole
afternoon
um and
um there was another problem I was very
slow in writing down things in Spanish
so I had a brilliant idea and that I
wrote a script for my presentation in my
mother tongue German and translated it
with Google translate
um into Spanish and I printed it out and
um just reached what what was there on
the on the sheet and to be honest the
outcome was not very good the grammar
was wrong and
the sentences they were very hard to
read and
um sometimes with multiple meanings were
translated wrong so all in all the
outcome was very disappointing
um now I would like to jump um forward
10 years till today and
um today
um I'm studying mathematics at the
University in Ulen Germany and I'm also
working as a data scientist at the unity
um where we want to explain predictions
for machine learning models so
um and coincidentally I'm also writing
my Master's thesis about Transformers
and nowadays I use a lot of tools that
help you to to write things down in
terms for example
um you probably also all know the tool
um the grammar tool that always tells
you that your sentences are hard and
water to read and this tool also tells
me
um every time that my sentence is
written in passive voice and they have
to change it into active voice and
um
today I think those tools are very
helpful
um helpful with um yeah text things and
um but what are the main reasons what
changed from um 2012 to now and um of
course among other reasons for example
um better data availability and ever
improving hard and software one major
aspect is the development of the
Transformer model and constantly I'm
also writing my thesis about this and
during this half year of writing the
thesis about Transformer models I
learned a lot of things and today I want
to share the
um we are amazing learnings that I have
that I've found especially cool and
helpful
um and I'm gonna try to yeah to share
this learnings with you today
and um I think um I had three main
learnings um during this time and um the
first one is I wasn't encoding decoder
is
um then the attention model and what is
this about
um with publicization in Transformer
models and some of these insights took
me a bit longer to understand and I hope
um that you will understand the details
faster through this talk today
um
let's get started with the very basics
of a transformer so
um
basically
um Transformer the Transformer
architecture was developed for for
translating text and you get us you give
a sequence in for example a sequence
um
a sentence in English for example sunset
at the beach you pass it to the
Transformer model which consists of an
encode and decoder and um
transformer for example translates this
sentence into into Spanish like I tried
10 years ago
yeah and
um because
the decoders basically an encoded
backwards we will only have a closer
look at the encoder today and what the
encoder does is
um it converts the input sequence into a
more meaningful Vector representation
and
um for this we want to have
um even closer look at the encoder and
the encoder basically consists of a
stack of many encoder so-called many uh
so-called encoder layers
um
and the input is passed from from one
encoder layer to the next encoder layer
and I'm there for every encoder layer um
consists of a for example a tension feed
forward normalization and Dropout layer
and here it is really important to
understand that those encoder layers all
have the same architecture
um
for example
um the famous bird encoder that some of
you may already heard about consists of
a stack of 12 identical encoder layers
um with the same architecture but they
don't
um have the same weights in the feed
forward length and also in the attention
layer
um
so far we know some basic stuff about
what an encoder is
um but you probably don't have that much
of an idea what an intent or what what
is that attention thing and the feed
forward layer and for this we want to
start at the very beginning of each
um
model and
um this is the input and for those of
you who have already worked with text
better you know that machine learning
models cannot process throughout Text
data and for these reasons and this word
they have to be converted into integers
and
um in this case
vectors and for this we all already use
a very smart method to get meaningful
vectors and the words they are converted
into so-called embedding vectors which
have the good property
that similar words are close together in
the vector space words that are not that
similar are further apart and in the
following example um you can see what
this means this plot shows a
three-dimensional Vector space with nine
um vector embeddings and um for example
um the vectors corresponding to pad
Mouse and dog they share plus and are
close together closer for example to
other words like
um like squash or baseball which are
sports
um
and at the beginning we always already
saw that the input is then passed to the
attention layer but what is that
attention thing
um
I hope your attention doesn't already
look like this if not I'm gonna try to
um
to explain what uh what the tension is
and for this we want to look again at
this three-dimensional Vector space and
we have a slight problem here
um we know that the natural language
um diff words can have different
meanings and depending on the context in
which they are used and for this a
single Vector representation for example
directory presentation for Mouse can I
cover every meaning and the rough idea
of attention is that it figures out in
which context the word is used and to
which words this word the specific word
is attending to and so basically
the main idea of attention is that we
wanna represent words as a weighted
average of all elements
um in the sequence and this gives us
then the possibility that we do not have
have a fixed Vector representation
forwards but each word in the sequence
is a combination of all the words in the
sequence for example we want to
calculate the weighted average for word
one
given word embeddings word one toward n
in our sequence and we have weights that
have fallen from heaven in this example
um
corresponding to the word one word one
to word n and for this
um
we get the weighted and with one just by
multiplying the sequence with the
weights
and um
but how do we we determine the weights
um
how do we determine them so
um for this
um we are calculating the similarity
between the vector embeddings
um in the sequence using a similarity
measure called for example one
um
uh most of the attention things that we
know and they um
use the use the top product and
um the dot product between two vectors
is calculated by melting directors
element wise and
um for this for example we have the word
Pi data and Global and the corresponding
Vector representation and then
we transform the words into our vectors
um and then we multiply the element wise
and taking the sum this is basically the
dot product
um
to show this
um what this really means um I want to
show you a little example
um we again have this two words and the
directors and um we just multiply
um the vectors element wise so for this
we take the first element of Pi data and
multiply with the first element of
global and then a second element of the
second element of global and so on and
so on
um and then we take the sun in this
example
um the dot product between the word
pilate and Global
um would be five
um
but
um the problem of the dog product is
um that it will have a high score
um to words that are similar and the low
dot product for words that are not
similar but in practice we know that the
meaning of the word
um is better informed by complementary
words
um so what does that mean let's consider
an example for that we have two
sentences the first sentence is I go to
the gym to transform math
and
um the second sentence is she took the
train to Berlin and um for us humans
it's pretty clear that
um in the first sentence
um the word train I refers to the verb
and
um probably will be good described by
considering the words Chim and marathon
on the other hand in the second sentence
um there were trained refers to the noun
and probably will be
um
good informed by considering the word
Berlin
and
um but how can we
identify words
um that describe the world best in our
sequence
and
um this is getting a bit tricky now
um
and for this I want to show you how this
is done in the attention module for this
instead of taking
um the original embedding vectors and
calculating the similarity in the
self-attention we transform
the words for example the word train
that we want to find the words that best
describe the word train in our in our
context
and for this we
linearly transform the vector embedding
corresponding to train into a so-called
query and key Vector
um by a linear transformation into
different
um dimensions of our Vector space and
this basically magically allows the dot
product to focus on different aspects of
the words
um
and
as I already said
um this is done by linear transformation
what is basically a multiplication with
numbers as we can see here we have a
weight a query rate and a key weight and
for this
um is how we calculate
um the query and the key vector
because this was probably a bit fast and
a bit confusing I will repeat this
procedure by showing and a little
example
um
we consider again
um our little a little sentence she took
the train to Berlin
um and we transform
all the words in the sequence into
embedding vectors as one to S6
and then we transform each
um of the embedding vectors
um into its corresponding query and key
vectors
um by our linear transformation
and the goal now is that we want to
determine weights that we figure out
words that describe the word train in
this context best
and for this and this is really
important now and for this
um
in this example we only want to do this
for for the for the fourth word uh when
the attention model you you
um always choose for do this for for all
the words but um this example we just
want to calculate the weights for the
for the fourth word train and for this
we map
um the query Vector that corresponds to
training with all the key vectors and I
want to show this uh with a little
example so
um and mapping in this context means
that we calculate on the dot product
which is our similarity measure in this
case
um and for this we
um
multiple we calculate the dot product
corresponding to the fourth query Vector
corresponding to the word train
um and calculate the dot product
um to P Vector one with which
corresponds to the word she and which is
for example 2.5 and the next we want to
calculate the dot product between the
fourth query Vector with the second T
Vector which corresponds to the word
took and which is for example 1.5
and so on
I think you get the the idea
and um since
um we want to calculate weights
um we we normalize
um the top product
um
normalization means in this case
um that we want
um to sum the dot product or the weights
we want to sum we want to have that they
sum up to one
and
um
the idea now is that instead of taking
the
um the vector embedding corresponding to
the word train
um we know that
um the fourth word in the sequence
um is virtually informed by taking the
average or the weighted average of all
the words in the sequence taking those
those weights that we calculated here
um and to get um to get a better idea of
what this means is
um I want to show you an example
um of the famous bird model
um and the attention scores to
um
to the words in in the sentences that I
showed you
and oh yeah I forgot this those are the
weights now that we want to use for for
our weighted average and
um for example
um I I brought you
um detention scores as I already told
you for our sentences the first sentence
again is I go to the gym to train for
Melton and the third model says that
were trained in this case
um is best informed by considering the
word marathon and Jim and the thickness
of the lines corresponds to the
um to the attention that the word train
has to all the words
in the sequence and the same for our
second sentence she took the train to
Berlin
and here you can see
um that the word train is best informed
by conserving
um Berlin Berlin and the word she
and
um this was
pretty much
um
one pretty cool
um learning that I had that the
attention module
um is basically a pretty clever
implementation of weighted average
um to be able to consider the context in
which the word is used in a sequence or
in a document or something
and
um
the second thing
um that I want to tell you
um is
um the parallelization thing because
this is also
um pretty cool in the Transformer models
that you you can
um paralyze things
and when processing
um sequences
and for this I also brought you a little
example so if you want to feed
um the sequence Pi data Global into our
um into our transforming model
um you pass the word pilot and Global to
the attention layer and the attention
layer as we already know magically
compute some weighted average and the
output is again two vectors and here we
have some dependencies
and you have to pass you have to
calculate
um all the corresponding vectors
but after that
um we can pass those vectors that we
that is the output of the tension layer
for example we rename them set one and
set two
um after that
um
those vectors that can be processed by
the feed forward layer in parallel so
you don't have any dependencies and this
is also
um I think a pretty cool thing to know
because in
earlier models before on the Transformer
architecture was developed for example
for recurring neural networks and this
was not possible so in recruit neural
networks
um you have to process
um and the elements of the sequence step
by step and in a Transformer
architecture after the attention module
we can process
those words in parallel
so
um this was pretty much everything I
want I
I prepared for today
um
thank you very much for listening and
I'm very curious about your questions
uh we have a question from Ellie
can you read it or yeah yeah
um that's
um yeah that's a pretty
um good question
um
we um this is what I told you when
um when I said that um the
transformation into query
um and key Vector
um allows um the dot product then
um to attend to um different aspects of
the words so
um and basically this linear
transformation into different dimensions
of the vector space allows this
um this distinction between different
semantic aspects of the world so um this
is why we we need the query and the key
vectors
and um the word
um no that's it thanks for the question
I hope this answered it
there is another question
[Music]
um the query and the key vectors
um they um they are also
um otherweights to get those query and
the key vectors
um those weights are also learned during
the training of the model
so basically
um you you get this await Matrix and
from the training and then you just
multiply it this is basically 10 matrix
multiplication
all right that's awesome
um
we still have some four more questions
um so far there are no more questions
foreign
questions thank you very much for having
me today
yes there is one final question yeah
just kidding sorry uh which live is uh
from python are good with
three um
hugging face for example is perfect
because
um a lot of
um yeah
um to a pre-trained Transformer models
um are
um available there and then you just
kind of don't download them and they
have
um you can either use it with pi torch
um or tensorflow as far as I know so
um depending on on which level you
prefer there
um there they have the possibility to
use it either with with either one of
them
so
yeah basically
um hacking face is pretty perfect for
that